la confirmation relevez le drone
accueillera bien la messe du pape oui ce
en pleine Coupe du monde de rugby le
Souverain Pontife célèbre aura donc bien
la grande messe ouverte au public dans
le mythique star de Drôme un stade 67000
places entre de l'Olympique de Marseille
qui sera effectivement transformé en
église pour l'occasion autre photo
farfelue généré avec l'intelligence
artificielle celle du soi-disant mariage
du pape François au Vatican qui circule
sur Tik Tok une fausse mariée qui est
des airs de Kate Middleton vous en
postez quoi alors j'aimerais finir par
en rendant un collègue disparu trop tôt
c'est Monsieur guillaume Bats alors on a
cherché une photo belle de Guillaume
batsson on en a pas trouvé mais on
voulait quand même lui rendre hommage
ici on fait des blagues sur tout sur le
handicap mais le boss de la discipline
le roi de l'autodérision c'était ce
jeune homme il va beaucoup manquer avec
Pierre Palmade c'est déjà le deuxième
humoriste qui nous quitte en 2023
triste année pour l'humour
c'est génial
a
c'est bien ça
un ministre devant la justice en
l'occurrence celui du travail Olivier du
soft sera jugé à l'automne pour
favoritisme dans le cadre d'une affaire
portant sur l'attribution d'un marché de
gestion de l'eau à la fin des années
2000 alors qu'il était maire d'Annonay
en Ardèche c'est le parquet financier
qui mène les investigations Olivier du
soft garde la confiance d'Élisabeth
borne fait savoir ce soir l'entourage de
la première ministre alors qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez
[Rires]
l'appareil est en effet installé de
sorte à avoir une vue directe sur la
douche qui dispose d'une paroi vitrée
j'étais sous la douche en train de me
laver et quand je me suis retourné mon
instinct m'a dit que c'était quand même
vachement bizarre parce que c'était
juste en face de moi dans le réveil
dissimulé derrière la face à teintée
elle découvre alors l'objectif d'une
caméra espion
le tirages étaient aléatoire les lettres
sont dans le désordre mais le tirage est
un peu perturbant je le reconnais une
fois le choc passé les deux amis
retirent la carte SD de l'appareil
quitte le logement et se rendent à la
gendarmerie pour déposer plainte prévenu
le propriétaire appelle alors Madison le
soir même pour s'excuser de son geste
depuis qu'il était seul il péter les
plombs et que il avait fait ça pour
combler un vide la caméra fonctionnait
depuis mars les enquêteurs cherchent
maintenant à retrouver d'autres
locataires qui auraient pu aussi être
filmés encore faut-il que les femmes
aient envie d'avoir des hommes avec des
gros pénis et en fait quand on leur
demande ce qui les intéresse dans un
pénis la longueur n'arrive qu'en 6e
position bien après son harmonie
générale la texture de sa peau et la
forme de sanglant mais quand même vous
dites je me la pète le soir je sors je
me la pète moi j'adore
ça fait du bien je veux dire parce que
quand on sort d'une relation qui est
très longue c'est vrai que on oublie un
peu peut-être ce côté séduction je sais
pas
[Musique]
moi personnellement si un jour il vous
faut un cavalier le soir pour sortir
c'est gentil
ce soir tous les deux ils vont nous
chanter un classique
ah je veux ton zizi Francky Vincent non
non
tu veux mon zizi c'est qui veut mon zizi
non tu veux mais dis donc c'est qu'elle
connaisse classique celle-ci alors
regarde-le avec sa petite
j'aime vivre ma sexualité à 100 %. ça
veut dire quoi bah ça veut dire ce que
ça veut dire
c'est quoi la question
non parce que samedi par exemple
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que c'est mieux après 50 bien sûr
que c'est mieux
[Rires]
[Musique]
et toi
quel signe qu'elle signe poisson
n'y pense à Mickey non
est-ce que vous pensez à Mickey à cette
heure là je sais pas ils ont dit Milou
Milou
vous êtes pas un radical
faut se méfier les gens ils sont parfois
plus carrés qu'on le pense
tous méditer là dessus j'ai la phobie de
Mister vin ah oui c'est Mr Bean
[Applaudissements]
en fait si je le vois à la télé en
acteur ça va mais si je le vois dans son
personnage de Mr Bean je vais avoir une
angoisse parce que sa tête me fait peur
quoi
c'était incroyable merci beaucoup
vraiment
[Applaudissements]
ils sont émus
très très fière de vous
c'était beau mais c'était